bonjour
monsieur Plaza
bienvenue dans mon petit coin
merveilleux je suis venu en tenue moi on
m'a dit c'est un camping un peu luxe je
suis venu comme ça ah mais là tu es au
top
comme personne m'a dit bonjour Fabrice
comment s'appelle cette personne
Fabrice Éboué
mardi sera un jour charnière pour notre
planète nous dépasserons alors la barre
des 8 milliards d'êtres humains selon
l'ONU en deux siècles la population
mondiale a été multipliée par 8
milliards d'habitants sur la planète
c'est 8 fois plus qu'il y a 200 ans
trois fois plus que dans les années 50
aujourd'hui plus de la moitié de la
population vit en Asie 59% loin devant
18% ou encore l'Europe
9%. la Chine est toujours le pays le
plus peuplé un milliard 430 millions
d'habitants mais plus pour longtemps
l'année prochaine ce sera l'Inde être
moins nombreux ce serait vraiment
salutaire pour l'environnement alors
c'est ce que suggère en tout cas
certains collapsologues vous savez ces
personnes qui anticipent un effondrement
généralisé cela diminuerait
mécaniquement notre empreinte carbone
certes mais en réalité le nombre
important moins que le mode de vie 1%
des plus riches dans le monde sont
responsables de 17% des émissions qu'en
50% des plus pauvres non totalisent que
nous vivons dans un monde de fou alors
avoir la possibilité de venir ici c'est
quoi cette chanson déjà
erika est loin très loin d'avoir des
soucis les bouffons du climat c'est une
expression que vous reprenez à votre
compte mais j'ai pas lu le journal mais
le bouffon ça va assez parce que
regardez les images tous ces gens qui se
collent les mains dans les musées sur la
route qui qui empêche les gens de je
veux dire à quoi ça sert qu'est-ce
qu'ils veulent prouver ou alors quand on
lance de la purée sur les sur les sur
les tableaux ce sont des bouffonneurs
il est compliqué d'établir un lien entre
le réchauffement climatique et
l'activité humaine il existe beaucoup de
causes naturelles pour expliquer que le
climat puisse changer deuxièmement il
n'est pas démontré que la concentration
des émissions de vous avez fait de serre
soit le facteur clé du réchauffement
troisièmement aucune solution n'est
possible pour stopper cette évolution
dans un temps court en clair toutes les
cops sont de la poudre aux yeux
c'est comme si l'ouragan avait fait des
bouchers sur cette cause
dépend de terre avalé des maisons
tronçonnées nettes ces restes de piscine
en équilibre ne vont pas tenir longtemps
la vue sur l'océan est devenue l'océan
dans la maison
je suis encore en état de choc j'arrive
pas à réaliser
on regarde leur situation urgence
climatique est plus importante que des
gens qui jettent pourtant ça me plaît
pas ce qu'ils font mais non mais c'est
parce que ces valeurs actuelles et que
bouffon ça vous choque tous les abdos
tous les abdos disent la même chose
vous avez des pruderies bouffon ça vous
choque
dans la presse partout il y en a partout
les bouffons j'espère qu'on en fait pas
partie quatrièmement arrêtons
d'instrumentaliser les événements météo
comme la canicule cet été météo et
climat n'ont rien à voir
autant vous dire que le livre de kunine
best-seller aux États-Unis qui sort en
France ces jours-ci et blacklisté dans
la presse bien-pensance en Amérique
comme en France les Maldives vont tout
du paradis
mais ce petit état composé de près de
1200 îles est aussi connu pour être l'un
des plus menacés au monde par la montée
des eaux
ici
80% du territoire se trouve à moins d'un
mètre au-dessus du niveau de la mer
d'après certaines études le pays
pourrait être submergées d'ici 2100
qu'aujourd'hui il y avait il y avait des
grèves il y avait la guerre il y avait
il y avait des problèmes de fric avec
tout bon j'ai pas emmerdé sur les
autoroutes ça je dois dire qu'on pouvait
rouler la vitesse
qui nous vraiment nous les cassent et il
y avait pas les vélos que je supporte
pas ouais il grille tous les feux rouges
le prochain je me le fait quand on tape
Tristan lopin sur Google Images c'est
sur qu'on tombe
vous allez montrer la photo
vous avez eu un accident de vélo vous
avez décidé de la médiatiser pourquoi
j'ai décidé
[Musique]
il s'est fait agresser par des
homophobes et j'étais là mais j'aurais
tellement préféré
parce que on aurait vendu des bières
quand on est près du soleil il faut
briller
très bien